so to start to get into today's content
uh so far we've been talking a lot about
few shot learning by using meta learning
and uh the problem set up for this was
we were given data from some number of
training tasks and we wanted to quickly
solve a new task more quickly more
proficiently or more stably
and we overviewed a few different
methods for doing that black box metal
learning methods optimization based meta
learning methods and non-parametric
methods
uh and one big assumption that these
algorithms make is that you have access
to a set of training tasks
uh and there may be scenarios where you
don't have a large number of training
tasks and so that's really the
motivation for the lectures that we're
going to be talking about and the topics
we're going to be talking about this
week
um and in particular we're going to be
considering scenarios where you only
have one large batch of unlabeled
examples and we want to kind of
pre-train models that allow us to
perform well with small amounts of data
perform well on new tasks with small
amounts of data by pre-training on this
unlabeled data
um and so in particular uh this week is
all about unsupervised representation
learning uh and the lecture today will
be on one class of methods for doing
that which is called contrastive
learning and the lecture on Wednesday
will be another class of methods for
doing that which are methods based off
of reconstruction
um and at the end of this lecture I'll
talk about kind of
it should be apparent as we kind of go
through the lecture but also talk about
how these methods relate to meta
learning methods it actually turns out
that there has actually is a pretty
close relationship between the methods
that we'll talk about today and the
methods that we've actually already been
talking about for the past two weeks
cool um so the goals for the lecturer to
understand contrastive learning
including the intuition design choices
and how to implement them and how these
algorithms relate to Better Learning
cool
um so unlike meta learning uh the main
data that we'll have access to an
unsupervised pre-training is a large
unlabeled data set and so that will have
a large set of examples denoted as x i
without their corresponding labels
and
the goal of this unsupervised
pre-training process is to take this
unlabeled data and produce a pre-trained
model such that when we take that
pre-trained model and fine-tune it on a
much smaller label data set we can do
well on our new task
so you can in many ways think of this as
the same setup as the metal learning
algorithms you've seen before except
instead of having access to a large
number of tasks we have access to this
diverse unlabeled data set
and then what we'll be talking about
this week is this first arrow on the
slide here where
um how do we basically go from that
diverse unlabeled data set to a
pre-trained model
um the unlabeled data set could be a
bunch of images that you found on the
internet it could be a bunch of
sentences or text it could also be
something more domain specific like if
if you're in an education domain maybe
it's a lot of student solutions to a
problem but you don't have feedback or
labels on those Solutions things along
those lines
cool and so today we'll be talking about
contrastive learning for unsupervised
pre-training and really the key idea
behind contrastive learning is that
we want to learn a representation
and specifically a mapping from inputs
to
a vector representation such that
similar examples have similar
representations
so examples that are semantically
related to one another should map to us
like map to points in space that are
closer than examples that have that are
semantically different from each other
um and so for example maybe you have two
examples with the same class label we
want to learn a representation space
such that these examples have a very
similar representation
of course if we did something like this
with um examples with class labels we
actually would need labels uh for those
examples in order to train those
examples to have similar representations
and this is very closely related to
things like Siamese networks and
prototypical networks where we're
training a network to predict whether or
not two examples had the same class
label or whether they had different
class labels
and so
yeah the stuff that we talked about on
Wednesday last week in some ways can be
viewed as a form of contrastive learning
but it requires labels and so what we
want to do is think about how we might
do something like that without access to
labels
and so there's a few different things
that we could imagine doing in
particular a few different ways that we
can imagine creating examples that might
be semantically similar to one another
one thing that we could do is we could
take an image and say that
patches of that image that are nearby to
one another probably should have a
similar representation because if
they're nearby to each other that means
that they're probably maybe from the
same object or from a similar part of
the same object
um and so that's what was done in the
CPC paper they tried to encourage those
patches to have a similar representation
instead of taking patches of an input we
could also augment an example
and so in this case we could take our
image and then we could flip it and also
crop it and say that the augmented
example should have a similar
representation as the original example
and if you're on if your augmentation's
if your augmentation is preserve the
class of the image then this should
produce representations that are uh that
correspond to this kind of semantic
categories that you may want it to
correspond to
um so something like this is uh was done
in the Sim clear paper
um there's also a version of this where
we can take videos and say that images
that are nearby in time from the same
video should have a similar
representation
so really the key idea behind
contrastive learning is to take
um things that we intuitively think
should have similar representations
encourage them to have similar
representations such that we can then
use that representation space in order
to do transfer to different Downstream
tasks
cool so then there's a question of um
how do we actually implement this
intuition and practice
so we can use a running example of
trying to say that like the two images
at the top have similar representation
and the two images at the bottom have
similar representations
um now one thing you could do is you
could say that maybe the the first image
is X the second image is X Prime and you
could train for a Model F that
encourages the representation of the
first image and the representation of
the second image
we could basically encourage this to
have to be kind of very close maybe a
euclidean space or in in some other
space
and we could
basically optimize for representation
functions such that these are close
together
um now does anyone see kind of a problem
with an objective like this
[Music]
yeah exactly
yeah so there's a degenerative solution
to this loss function which is to
basically just map everything all of the
images to a single constant vector and
then you would minimize this loss
function very nicely because you would
you would achieve zero loss here
but it means that you don't get a very
good representation phase
and so
um we can't simply minimize the
difference between these representations
because uh because of that collapse and
instead of only comparing examples and
saying that examples should have similar
representations we also need to say what
needs to be different we need to also
contrast the the images as well
and so that's one of the key ideas
behind contrastive learning
and so in particular if we take these
three examples here we have our
embedding space
then we could try to train for our
embedding space in a way that
first embeds these examples and then
brings together the representations of
similar examples while also pushing
apart the representations of different
examples
um and so
this is basically the key idea behind
contrastive learning and from here
there's really just only two key design
choices Behind These algorithms the
first is how do you actually implement
the loss function we'll go over two
different loss functions in this lecture
but there's actually
a number of loss functions that people
have used in practice
and then also choosing what to compare
and contrast we talked about some
options at the very beginning with the
pictures of the dogs but there's other
other considerations there as well
cool so let's first get into the kind of
implementation of the loss function for
contrastive learning
so
um
the first
um I guess in terms of first some
terminology
if we want to bring two examples
together and push apart two examples
typically we'll refer to the first
example as the anchor because that's
what we're going to be comparing and
contrasting to
and then we'll refer to the next example
as a positive example
and the third example is the negative so
the pot we're trying to bring the
positive towards the anchor and push the
negative away from the anchor
uh and really the simplest form of loss
function is uh referred to a triplet
loss
and
we can start by just taking the loss
function that we wrote down before and
instead of only minimizing the distance
between the embedded x and x Prime we
can also add a term that basically
maximizes the distance between and
actually using the notation here we'll
call this X Plus that will also maximize
the distance between the embedded X and
the negative so this would correspond to
uh
F Theta of x
minus
F Theta of x minus
squared
um
and because we have a negative here
we're going to be maximizing this
distance when we minimize this overall
objective function
yeah so the question is what happens if
you actually have a lot of different
negatives that you want to contrast
against and we'll get into that actually
after after this slide
yeah is there a way
um so that you can control how much you
push away
yeah so the question is is there a way
to control how much you push away from
the contrasting examples and there's
actually two different aspects of that
question one is that maybe for some
examples you want to push away more than
others uh and
in practice contrastive learning
algorithms will push away the same
amount for all of the negatives uh but
that doesn't mean that all of them will
end up at the same distance because some
of them will naturally be harder to push
away than others and so oftentimes even
if you push apart all of them the same
amount they will
um
they'll still give you kind of a
meaningfully the distances in the space
will be meaningful
but the second part of that question is
there's actually an issue with this loss
function to some degree
um which is that
uh this term of the loss function
uh is is somewhat unbounded uh
which is that you can kind of basically
put this to Infinity you can make them
like maximally far apart
um and so when designing
um either your embedding function or
your loss function you need to make sure
that you don't have an unbounded loss
function otherwise it will go to
negative infinity and there's a few
different ways to accomplish this one
thing that you could do is you could
make sure that your embedding space is
normalized in some way is bounded itself
but one thing that's common to do with a
triple loss is to actually use a hinge
loss here which is that instead of
um kind of rewarding it more and more
the more that it pushes away it says
that once it's a certain distance away
then it no longer gets rewarded for
pushing it any further
um and so you probably have seen
something like a hinge loss in um
in like a machine learning class before
um the way it looks like is if we look
at
um
the
um the distance
we want to
um
in this case or or the kind of the
difference of these distances basically
as this increases we want it to get a
lower loss so the the y-axis here is
going to be the loss value
so as it increases we want it to get a
lower loss but at some point we want it
to not
um continue getting rewarded because it
doesn't need to push it all the way to
negative infinity and so what a hinge
loss would do is basically give you a
shape that looks like this
um where up until some point it's going
to be rewarded for increasing the
distance and after that it will be
um it will just sit at zero loss
uh and
this kind of
this distance right here is referred to
as your margin
uh and this is something that you can
control this is like a hyper parameter
and this controls how much you are how
far apart you want your examples to be
um and so the way that you actually
will implement this is um instead of
having your loss function be the just
the difference between these two things
you're going to
um
first you will add your margin maybe
your margin is referred to as Epsilon
and then you will basically bound this
below by zero and so you can take the
max between this
um and zero and this will basically just
apply this function to
um
to what we had before
and then we'll minimize this whole thing
with respect to Theta
and so that loss function is written out
right here
yeah
um
yeah so the question is where do X X
Plus and x minus come from
yeah so
um they can come from these triplets can
come from a number of different places
uh the
in one case it could if you have labels
then it could come from the um whether
or not examples have the same label so
you could sample two examples with the
same label and one example with a
different label and that would give you
an anchor a positive and a negative
um one of the other things that we
talked about is instead of using class
labels you can also use augmentations
and so you could sample an example and
Sample a different example that will be
the anchor and the negative and then to
get another positive you can augment and
create another view of the anchor by for
example cropping applying a random crop
or flipping the image or doing something
like that
incorrect
um so in practice you'll say you'll sell
mini batch of these triplets uh and the
so you'll sample
um you'll sample not just one triplet
but you'll sample a mini batch of them
that's what you should wear each of the
mini magic which is
x minus relatively
yeah absolutely so yeah to sample and
anchor you can basically
um when you sample an image from your
unlabeled data set that can be the
anchor you sample a different image and
that can be the negative and then
generate the positive you can augment
the anchor
to get the positive
so we'll also render an algorithm too
which should maybe give a little bit
more intuition for this yeah
um what if I the negative examples are
accidentally including the same class
of dating group
um how bad is that in the training
process yeah so the question is
um what happens if the negative example
is accidentally kind of the same class
as the anchor uh and this is generally a
great question
um and in in practice especially when
you have unlabeled examples and you're
contrasting against augmentations uh you
will sample negatives that may actually
be somewhat similar to the example that
the anchor that you sampled
um this is okay uh the most important
thing is that
um
well the most important thing is that
the that happens somewhat rarely and so
if General if you have a really huge
data set
um the
and and you just want to kind of uh yeah
if you have a huge data set then the uh
the number of examples that you have
from a particular class will be somewhat
small and the likelihood of actually an
anchor and a negative being very similar
to each other
um will also be small
yeah
embedding space in the distance metric
make a big difference
here
in space you can get different
combinations of distances I'm wondering
if that's helpful does the distance
function here is that important or
you're asking something different
uh not even so much like how how helpful
it is to do that
yeah I think that there's really two
common choices one is to use euclidean
and another is to use
um kind of basically negative cosine
similarity uh I
to my knowledge it's not
um it's not critical and and
um you probably want to
consider both of those two options but
beyond that I don't think that people
get super creative
which is positive
yeah so one thing that's different here
is that these positives and negatives
are they're actually quite different
from a class label
um and they they may not correspond
exactly to your class labels
um
they're going to instead correspond to
some some other
um kind of notion of relatedness and so
forth
um
sorry what was your question
[Music]
yeah so I'll go back to the slide that I
had here so augmented versions are the
top right
um beyond that there's
um I have two other examples here one is
to use image patches or to use basically
um in this case they actually often use
overlapping image Patches from the same
image
um or if you have a video you can use
nearby frames uh and these are also
somewhat popular choices as well
um in computer vision augmented versions
is like the definitely the most popular
example of this
um but using things like basically
things that are nearby in some space
either in image space or in time or
something else is also very popular
I guess I'll also provides some
intuition for that for example with
video frames
um kind of the the intuition there is
that things that co-occur in time will
be related to one another
um but it does end up being fairly data
dependent and if your data
um if your data
for whatever reason doesn't um doesn't
obey that like if you have videos that
are constantly changing over time
um and don't and like are are more
random in terms of their sequence then
that may yield representations that
aren't as good as something that has a
little bit more temporal coherence
yeah so you can view augmentations
essentially as a form of hyper parameter
or as a form of domain knowledge that's
going into the algorithm and the choice
of augmentation is actually really
really important to actually how the
performance ends up that these
algorithms ends up being there's
actually a lot of
literature on different forms of
augmentations that work well for
um often for for images and there's also
some work outside of computer vision
domains that look at other augmentations
as well but it does end up being quite
important
um and so if you look at for example
um The Sim clear paper I know that they
included a study of different kinds of
basically how well different kinds of
augmentations work
ERS
um there is actually paper that
discovers augmentations and I'll I'll
cover it later in the lecture
cool
um so
we've talked about the triplet loss um
and so that's what we went over on the
board and this is really the simplest
form of contrastive loss uh and it it
actually works pretty well uh and
um
yeah it's it's pretty nice a good place
to start
uh compared to something like Siamese
networks which we talked about on
Wednesday
um it's actually extremely similar to
Siamese networks especially if you're
using class labels as
um as your positives and negatives
and you can essentially think of it as
Siamese networks from the standpoint of
uh if if this distance in your embedding
space is small then classify the
examples as being the same class
otherwise classify them as being in a
different class
um really the key difference between
this triple loss and Siamese networks is
that
when you use this triplet loss to learn
a representation you're going to be
learning this kind of metric space this
representation space from which you can
measure the distance between examples
um whereas the Siamese networks will
only lose learning a classifier and it
was just giving you the probability that
they were correct or not rather than a
representation where you can measure
these kinds of distances
cool
um now one thing that's that comes up in
this um
with this this loss function is that
the negatives
um choosing good negatives is difficult
and in particular if you're in your
embedding space and you sample a
negative that's already very far away
then you're just going to have zero loss
at that at that space and you won't
actually be learning anything from that
negative
and so you really want to try to find
negatives that are difficult
uh one thing that you could do is what's
called hard negative mining where you
explicitly search for negatives that are
closer and use those negatives to
actually allow it to continue to learn
and continue to getting getting good
gradients from this loss function
um
but the we can also just basically
um essentially instead of just sampling
one negative we can sample multiple
negatives and incorporate that into the
loss function as well
um and this gets out the question that
was asked before which is what if I
don't want to contrast against one thing
what if I want to contrast against
multiple different things
and so
um the second version of the loss
function that will look like
function is something that is going to
do more of an end way classification
rather than these binary comparisons
uh and so instead of thinking about just
having one negative we're also going to
think about having multiple other
negatives
and essentially what we'll what we're
going to want to be able to do is
classify among
the turquoise and and pink and yellow
and salmon colored dots which of those
is the positive and which one is the
negative
or which one is a negative
um and so
if we want to perform that kind of
classification it's going to look a lot
like a soft Max
so we can measure the distance between
the positive and the anchor and the
negative in the anchor or the negatives
in the anchor
and what our kind of the probability
that an example will be
um the positive will be something like e
uh to the negative distance between X
and X Plus
divided by
basically a soft Max so we're just going
to exponentiate and normalize these
distances where we're dividing by the
distance between
um the anchor in each of the negatives
and so
um this basically gives you the
probability that X Plus is a positive
example rather than being a negative
example
and when you actually then compute the
loss for this uh oh actually sorry the
these should technically I guess be f of
x or equivalently you could write these
as D of Z
or D of z and d of Z Plus
and D of Z
and D of Z minus so D will just
correspond to either
the euclidean losses before or something
like negative cosine similarity
and then what the law function looks
like is
um this is the probability we'll just
minimize the negative log probability so
we'll
take the log of this and minimize this
with respect to Theta
yeah
something over the next of examples
oh yeah sorry this is something over the
negative examples and so yeah great
catch so this is over n and then this is
um
Z minus n
icely
yeah so we need to know during training
we need to know what the positives and
negative examples are
um
we don't a priori know how good of a
negative they are but this loss function
will
um will basically take into account all
of them
yeah
um could be also some over all the
negative examples using the triplet loss
yeah so um the question was can we also
sum over all the negatives using the
triplet loss
um this actually ends up being very very
similar to doing that so uh if you
actually write this out
um with the log uh the new the numerator
will become log of e to the negative
distance and so or negative log of
either negative distance and so
you this actually just becomes D of Z
and Z Plus and then with the denominator
you get something like
um
plus log of sum of e to the negative
distance of Z and Z minus
um and so you have a log some X pure but
um if you basically think of the log and
the E canceling out this is basically
just like summing up the distances there
yeah sorry I didn't get that can you
easily explain like what you're trying
to achieve here yeah so the question was
just
um the
the question was can we just basically
take the triplet loss and just add up
all the negatives and
what I was simply saying is that this is
this loss function is actually already
very similar to the triplet loss but
where you sum over the negatives here
um and so the question is why don't we
just do something like this
and this loss is actually already doing
something a lot like that except instead
of something we're going to do a log sum
X but no no
oh sorry yeah what is the loss function
doing itself so
um yeah there's a few different kind of
intuitive ways to think about this loss
function
um one is is very similar to the triplet
loss which is that it's pulling together
the things the positive and the anchor
and pushing apart or maximizing the
distance between the anchor and the
negatives the second intuition that you
can think of it as is basically
classifying
um whether or not an example is a
positive example or a negative example
given the anchor
um and so this is
um this is looks a lot like a soft Max
uh where
um your logits correspond to this
negative distance between uh the example
your example and the anchor
you guys focused have a hard time
grasping why
um the top is positive and the bottom is
something over negative examples
like the I'm sorry for this loss
function on the do I yeah it's it says
like C plus
but where some people are negative
examples
um for the bottom part and I'm I'm not
sure why that's
yeah so the well so I guess one other
form of the sauce function that I can
mention is one where you you just sum
over all the examples on the bottom and
so you also
add something where the positive example
also comes on the bottom
I don't know if that makes more sense to
you
um so yeah this is also a version that
you can do uh this is I think this
version actually I think is what is done
in this first paper whereas in the
second paper they actually didn't
include this
um and I think that the intuition
perhaps for not including it is that
um is that you really only want to push
apart the
um you really only want to push apart
the anchor and the negatives you don't
really want to push apart the anchor and
the positive
and this denominator is basically
pushing them apart yeah
Journey knowledge about the class
obviously
um the first one was knowledge about the
class of Z
but in the unlabeled case you don't have
any knowledge about the class of any of
the examples
yeah the question is why would you then
want the anchor to be closer to Z Plus
versus Z minus this comes down to how we
sample positives and negatives and so on
the next slide I'll talk about how we
sample it
yeah the question is can we interpret
hard negative mining as a form of
adversarial loss and yeah exactly so
basically
um if you're the way that it would look
like in the case of the triple OS for
example is you find the negatives that
maximize this loss function rather than
minimize those and specifically pick
those and so in some ways it is a form
of an adversarial or a form of an
adversary
cool
um so
here's the loss function
um just kind of written out on the board
um I talked a little bit about how this
is in some ways a generalization of the
triplet loss to multiple negatives
now
um let's actually walk through
one algorithm that explicitly walks
through also how we sample the positive
and negatives and I think that that
should help
um clear out clear up what has been
clear up some of the questions that have
been asked
so
um the input to this algorithm is just a
set of examples X just unlabeled
examples
and so what the Sim clear algorithm does
is it samples a mini batch of those
examples so it samples n of those
examples
and to generate positives it's going to
augment those examples with some
augmentation function and so here we're
sampling some images which which are our
mini batch of examples and we're going
to augment each of those examples twice
to get X tilde and X tilde Prime
uh and so for example the augmentations
here correspond to changing the color
cropping in different ways
um and uh and distorting or flipping and
so forth
and so for example we take our example
then we augment in two different ways to
get and do that for every example in our
mini batch
then once we have these augmentations
we're going to embed our augmented
examples into our embedding space so
this corresponds to just running
each of these augmented examples through
our encoder F data
and then from there
the positives are going to correspond to
augmentations of the same image
and the negatives are going to
correspond to augmentations of different
images
and so the things that we're going to
try to bring together are these
augmentations of the same image and the
things that we're going to try to push
apart are basically everything else in
the batch
so this is one way to generate positives
negatives there's also other ways to
generate positive negatives that we'll
talk about
um on a future slide
and so intuitively we don't know the
classes of these images but we do know
that
if we design good augmentations then the
augmented versions these are actually
very different images but they have the
same class because they're generated
from the same image
um and likewise these have these have
different different classes and so forth
um
as was mentioned before it's possible
that you'd also sample a chair in this
batch and you might end up pushing apart
uh other chairs uh
that's okay as long as the um as long as
you're not every example you're pushing
apart is also a chair
you could also think of this as doing
something
a form of more fine-grained
classification where you're basically
trying to discriminate different
instances rather than different classes
did I answer your question
[Music]
images of chairs so they might be
separate but the relative distance
between two chairs would be lesser than
the relative distance within a chair and
at all yeah exactly so the result of
this algorithm should be
an embedding space such that chairs are
closer to each other than chairs and
dogs uh and
part of that also relies on your
augmentation function and ideally your
augmentation function will generate
other things that look like chairs and
so by pulling together those things that
will make it more difficult for the
network to push apart an example of a
different chair because you have because
you have to have these have a similar
representation
yeah
yeah so you could also just augment once
and basically use the anonymous
unaugmented example as the anchor and
the augmented example as as the positive
um
one thing that this does give you is it
gives you more negatives
um and and more more anchors and more
positives and so uh if you have a good
augmentation function I think that
augmenting twice and using augmented
examples both as anchors and positives
and negatives
um should work well I would also expect
that if they include some of the
original examples as as positives
anchors and so forth or basically have
the identity function be part of your
augmentation class that would also be a
very reasonable choice
yeah it's fine it is not a part of
domination you said isn't it is
kind of because it's only been trained
on augmented samples which is
yeah so the question was if the identity
function isn't in your augmentation
class then like will these images be out
of distribution in comparison to these
images
um in general these augmentation classes
are designed such that they
are exhaustive and that they cover a
much wider space than the original space
um and such that they aren't completely
disjoint from the original space and so
um in practice that ends up not being an
issue if you design your augmentations
well but it does mean that when you
design your augmentations you shouldn't
design it to to basically be disjoint
from your original space
yeah so we're not embedding the original
examples at all yeah in this case we're
not actually well and so far if if
identity is included in your
augmentation class than we are but um if
it's not then we're not actually doing
that
yeah so if this is completely
unsupervised then can't we
accidentally sample like two duels
instead of a dog in a chair
yeah so
um if this was completely unsupervised
can't we accidentally
temple two dogs rather than a dog in a
chair and and yes uh the this relies on
the fact that
um
that kind of sampling two dogs is less
likely than sampling a dog and something
else
um it also relies on the fact that when
you augment you will create
um you'll create things that you have to
push together and that will make it
harder to push apart to dogs than it is
to push apart a chair and a dog
cool and so just to finish out the
algorithm we talked about attracting and
repelling attracting things of the same
image augmentation is the same image and
repelling augmentations of different
images
um what this ends up looking like is
once you embed into your Z space then in
this case they're using cosine
similarity to compute the distances
between all of the different pairs of
augmented examples
and what the loss function ends up
looking like is um basically exactly
what we have written on the board here
where we take the distance between
um
between the two augmented versions of
the same image so that's going to be Z
and Z Plus here it's written as z i
tilde and Zi Prime tilde so the I is the
same that means that they're from the
same original image
and then the denominator is over
examples that are
um
that are of um of different
initial images
and so those are an augmentation of one
image versus an augmentation of another
image
yeah
using this noise
because it is a huge imbalance
this might not work
yeah so the question is does this
algorithm assume that your unlabeled
data is unbalanced and in particular if
it's unbalanced and you have like a ton
of dogs and only a small number of
chairs
then maybe it wouldn't work well uh
that's a great question I don't know of
any
I don't know if he works off the top of
my head that have analyzed that although
I vaguely remember some Works showing
that
in general these algorithms can work
um much less well if your data is not
balanced and this is actually a really
important
thing to keep in mind because
data sets like images that are balanced
because we know the labels of the data
set or they're more balanced because we
know the labels but in cases where we
don't know the labels we have no way of
telling if they're balanced or not
because we don't know the labels and so
the um yeah it's in general in practice
when putting these algorithms
um into into practice it's important to
keep that in mind
um if you also want to add I can also
potentially try to point you to things
that have specifically looked at
unsupervised learning with imbalanced
data
cool um and so you apply this process
iteratively to update your encoder and
once you have your encoder you can then
either train a classifier on top of that
representation or fine-tune the entire
network
one other design Choice I'll mention
um it's not kind of written in the
equations but the the simpler paper
found it pretty helpful to
um to actually use the representation
right here as your pre-trained
representation rather than the one right
here and that means that there's this
kind of additional projection head
that's taking the representation
projecting it into another space and
then doing
um doing the compare and contrast in
that other space
uh and they found that this this made
performance um somewhat better and you
can imagine that it gives a little bit
more flexibility
to the network although it also
introduces additional hyper parameters
in determining like where should this
representation be in the network
[Music]
um
because I'm thinking for example for
example in Easterns supposedly maybe in
the first second book uh both are for a
similar test right in the English
formula they still want you I mean make
these 10 smarter because
the denominator here is always examples
that have always augmentations of
different examples although they may be
examples of of the same class which we
had mentioned before and ideally that
happens with low lower probability than
examples with uh of the same or of
different classes
yeah
[Music]
other group performance for this
algorithm so this unit can be Network
better
the question is can you net perform
better for these contrastive algorithms
so we'll talk more about architectures
that reconstruct the input in the
Wednesday lecture
um I don't think you necessarily need
something like a unit here because this
representation doesn't need to be this
like a very large image
um it can be it can still be much lower
dimensional or lower dimensional
yeah you can also yeah imagine having
like skip connections here for example
yeah I think that you could you could
imagine doing something like that I
guess
I don't know of any papers that do that
um but my intuition would say that that
could be bad from the standpoint of like
it could just completely ignore this
part and just use the representation
like use the information through those
skip connections to do the contrastive
learning
um but that's that's somewhat
speculative and I I don't know of any
papers that do that
cool so
um how will these algorithms actually
work for learning representations so the
um here are some results from the paper
from the algorithm that we just went
over and here they're comparing to
image.classification uh the top five
accuracy
and they're looking at if you only use
one percent of the imagenet labels or
ten percent of the imagenet labels uh
and here one percent corresponds to
about 12.8 images per class and 10
corresponds to about 128 images per
class
um and so once you get down to one
percent you're
um almost in the few shot learning
regime or possibly you could consider
that in the future learning if you kind
of have 10 to 15 examples per class
um
and we're comparing to a baseline that
only trains on with supervised learning
on those labeled examples as well as
some semi-supervised learning methods
and some other representation learning
methods
and the results showed that
um first you get really substantial
improvements over just supervised
training from scratch you go from in the
one percent case from 48 accuracy to 85
accuracy
which is pretty significant
um and you also see pretty significant
improvements over other semi-supervised
and unsupervised methods uh and this
um
we see this kind of especially as as
being the case in the one percent label
setting uh so for example in comparison
to um well CPC which is another
contrasted method we see about a seven
percent performance Improvement
um compared to big bike and you see a 30
Improvement and so forth
so these methods work pretty well and
overall 85 accuracy on imagenet is uh I
feel like not too shabby um and it's
nice that we can get that while using
only one percent of the labels in the
data set
yeah
oh yeah what does the 2X and 4x mean so
um resonant 50 is the standard resnet 50
architecture 2x means that the width of
the Hidden layers is 2x larger and 4x
means it's 4X larger so it's just a
larger Network um and we we see that it
does better with larger Networks
what about when using 10 of the labels
yeah so we see that the performance
um it also does quite well on the 10
setting the um the performance
improvements are somewhat smaller and
there's a semi-supervised method that
gets 91.2 whereas this gets 92.6 but it
is still
um kind of the best method out of um
compared to the methods that were state
of the art in 2020.
dad did you saying that you only get 12
pointed and with labeled images but you
also get other images that are unlabeled
or this is only 1200 images sorry yeah
they're using the entire unlab the
entire image that data set as unlabeled
and then they're only using one percent
of the labels
and we know we also training to the same
images
are the representations useful Beyond
just image.classification do the
representations generalize well uh the
short answer is they do generalize to
some degree and we'll see some results
um in towards the end of the lecture on
it
cool
um and then there's one other experiment
that I think is actually quite important
in the Sinclair paper that was looking
at
I'm not just performance but how
performance varied with the number of
training epochs and the batch size
and the results are here so the x-axis
is the number of training epochs or how
long you're training for and the
different bars within each of those
correspond to the batch size with the
blue on the left being the smallest
batch size of 256 which is still a
decently large batch and
um the bar on the far right being about
size of 8192.
and
um it's important to train for 600 plus
epochs I think this isn't too surprising
in unsupervised learning settings
because you
um you need to learn a lot about the
data
um one thing that I think is
perhaps more important to note here is
that it requires a large batch size so
if you train on with a batch size of 256
um that does a lot worse than if you
train on about size of a thousand for
example and that differences can be
um if you train for a really long time
that difference is only two percent if
you train for a shorter amount of time
that difference can be
um more than five percent
yeah
yeah so why does it need a large
baptized
[Music]
um
so
we'll talk about this both intuitively
and more mathematically so
one way to interpret
um interpret the contrastive loss
function is basically you're trying to
classify between
um classify kind of one image from all
the other images in the data set
and
the um you can sort of think of this
kind of the denominator of this loss
function is trying to sum over all the
other examples in the data set you're
trying to classify between one example
and everything else
um and
in the summation right here uh
the examples the negatives that have the
smallest distance are really going to
dominate the sum because we're
exponentiating here and so something
that has a distance of say like 0.01
versus a distance of 10.
um because we're exponentiating this
this is going to play a much like e to
the negative 0.01 versus e to the
negative 10. this is a much much larger
number and so this is going to be play a
much larger role in the summation right
here
and this means that
um
the because these examples with a really
small distance are dominating if you're
sub sampling and having a much a smaller
batch size then you might miss the
examples that actually dominate that
loss function
um and so you're not actually going to
get a very good estimate of your loss
function if you're missing the examples
that actually have like play the largest
role in this summation
um so that's that's part of the
intuition
um
and then
more mathematically if we want to think
about this
um
Let's uh
let's think about whiteboard space so
I guess this is well
so this is our loss function right here
um I'm going to also remove this just
because
this is what CPS or this is what
simclear does
um so this is our loss function
um
you can essentially think of as think of
what we do when we sub-sample as
sort of bringing this summation outside
of the log
um and
I guess specifically
um maybe one one thing the first note is
that
in normal supervised learning we
sub-sample all the time it's not a
problem uh and so in this totally fine
to have small batches and the reason for
that is our kind of typical loss
function might be something like log
probability of Y given X where this is
kind of a summation over X comma y
and
when this is our loss function
if we if we sub-sample and Sample a
smaller batch of X and Y
well still in expectation get the
correct gradient
now
things are a little bit different when
we actually tried a sub-sample from this
summation right here
and in particular if we write out this
loss function
um
it ends up looking like first
the distance bit or yeah the distance
between Z NZ plus this is all fine
um
plus the log of the sum Over N of
uh e to the negative
D of Z and z n minus
and the trouble here is right now this
summation is inside of the log
and essentially when we sample mini
batches what we're doing is we are
saying that well maybe this is like
approximately equal to
D of Z of Z Plus
plus a sum over
mini batch
Times log of sum over
kind of n in our mini batch
of e to the negative D of Z comma ZN so
this is really what we're optimizing
when we do mini batch sampling because
instead of sampling all of the negatives
in our entire training data set we're
sampling a mini batch of them
and
now there's a question of okay what
what actually happens like what's the
relationship between these two equations
and there's something called Jensen's
inequality that's actually super useful
um and
one of the things that Jensen's
inequality can tell us is it tells us
that
um log
sum of X I always forget which way it
goes
um is greater than or equal to the
summation of log X
rewrite this
and so what this means is that it means
that when we take the summation on the
outside that gives us a lower bound
compared to when it's on the inside
and so that means that this
approximation right here
when we actually are doing this sort of
minibatch sampling
uh we're getting a lower bound
on our original objective
and that means that when we actually
minimize the subjective
we're actually minimizing a lower bound
on our original objective
uh and
it's not good to minimize lower bounds
on things because then you may not
actually be minimizing your original
objective
uh
and so that's what that's I guess some
additional intuition for why having a
larger batch size is helpful because
basically
um we're not actually getting a bound on
our objective and so if we sample
something closer to our original data
set then we're actually going to come
closer to optimizing our original
objective
any questions on that
we also control somehow how close
um the question is is there a way to
control how tight the bound is
um I mean
you can like one thing that you could do
is just sample your whole data set
rather than sample many batches although
that's sort of what we're trying to get
away from
um or to sample larger batches so I mean
that's kind of why large are about to
make sense
um I don't know of any way to to
to make it tighter but if you do let me
know
cool
um so yeah the kind of summary is that
in normal mini batch deep or normal mini
about supervised learning the summation
is already on the outside and we're all
good until we can estimate this with
mini batching when the summation is on
the inside of a log uh
then mini batching dot is not really
kind of the correct thing to do
but as we do it anyway because that's
what deep learning is like
so and then I also wanted to go through
kind of solutions to requiring a large
batch size
so
um
one thing that you could do is instead
of uh instead of trying to sample your
entire data set at every single
iteration you can
basically store the representations from
the previous batches with something that
looks a lot like momentum
uh this is not exactly correct because
your encoder is going to be changing
over the course of training and so if
you store those previous representations
they're going to be a little bit stale
but it allows you to somewhat decouple
the batch size from
from this estimate and it allows you to
get away with smaller batch sizes
because you're basically accumulating
batches over multiple iterations
this is called momentum contrast or Moco
and they were able to get good results
with a mini batch size of 256.
another thing that you can do that was
um proposed in the literature is instead
of having any negatives whatsoever I
simply try to predict the representation
of your image under a different
augmentation this is kind of more of a
predictive method it's called bootstrap
your own latent
it actually doesn't require any
negatives it just requires examples of
positives and when they plotted
performance with respect to batch size
they found that it dropped off much less
especially up until 256 in comparison to
the Sim clear method
um and so it's more resilient to batch
size although it's something that's also
um
doesn't have some of the
kind of nice contrastive interpretation
that we've talked about so far
um and then overall in terms of the
performance of these methods uh if you
actually look at how good they are in
terms of self-supervised learning for
imagenet accuracy we see that like some
of the papers that we covered were from
a couple years ago but they really
remain near state of the art for a
self-supervised pre-training and in
particular you can see Moco V3 is um is
like very close to the state of the art
I haven't actually looked at what is
exactly the state of the Arts I'm not
sure if it may also be a contrasted
method or maybe something that's a
little bit different
yeah
sum up with some long needs to be of
some samples and then assume them
like it would be a number one right if
he is
like instead of going this way uh can we
just like take the logs on me EXP
erience
um so you're saying that why like why do
we have this loss function in the first
place like why not have this um outside
of the log or
um if you move the sum outside of the
log then it becomes a lower bound
um according to Jensen's inequality so
if the sum is on the outside it's a
lower Bound in comparison to if it's on
the inside
yeah and unfortunately like sometimes I
wish Jensen's inequality went the other
way
um but yeah
[Music]
yeah so the question was a lot of image
that images just have one example or one
object in the image uh and would this
work if you have multiple objects in an
image
um the I guess I don't know of any like
specific detailed experimental studies
on that but I'll show
um a couple instances where contrastive
learning has been used in settings
outside of imagenet and that might
provide some kind of some answer to your
question
cool
um and so I guess moving towards that to
some degree
um these methods have been really good
for visual categorization things like
imagenet and
one challenge that comes up is that
we've mostly been focusing on
augmentations and there's a lot of
scenarios where we don't have
a good like hand engineered augmentation
function that we can use for these
methods
and even in those cases the general
framework of contrastive learning can
still be very useful
and so
one kind of alluding to something that
came up earlier you can actually try to
learn the augmentation function uh and
this is a really cool paper that
actually basically formulated
um an adversarial optimization where for
your augmentation function you tried to
optimize it in a way that maximized the
contrast of loss
of course if you do this in a completely
unbounded space then it will just give
you arbitrary images out but what you
can do is you can say that that
augmentation function it can only change
the image by a small amount within some
L1 sphere
uh and uh this paper was actually
competitive with simclear on image data
which means it was able to find
augmentations that were as good as the
hand engineered augmentations
um and it was also able to get good
results on domains that aren't images so
domains like speech data uh and and
sensor data
um cool and then one other thing that we
had mentioned earlier is instead of
using augmentations we could use
um basically our positives could be
frames in a video that are nearby in
time and the negatives could be things
that are further away in time or from
other videos
and there have been a number of papers
that have done something like this and
they've been able to get good results on
tasks like robotics tasks and so
um in this paper the um you can take a
basically a data set with a ton of
diverse videos of humans
um do this sort of time contrastive
learning where you pull together frames
that have similar representations and
push apart frames that have different
representations
um and there was also an additional loss
that sort of did a form of contrastive
learning between videos and language
and it found that if you use this to
pre-train a representation you can give
a robot 20 demonstrations or less than
10 minutes of supervision and get a um a
policy that looks uh something like this
uh get a gets around 60 success rate on
putting lettuce in a pan and 40 success
rate on folding a towel
um and then the last thing I'll
highlight is um this isn't really fully
self-supervised but you can also apply
contrastive learning between images and
text
and what this looks like is you learn a
representation of the images you learn a
representation of the text if you have
data that tells you whether or not that
basically kind of captions an image then
you can tell it that captions
um and images should go together and
images and other captions or yeah images
and other captions should be pushed
apart
um and so this is the key idea behind a
model called clip uh and it is actually
a really performant model
um and it can it gives you very useful
representations it also can give you
very good zero shot classification
performance so on imagenet it was able
to
um give you image of accuracy that
matches a supervised reznut but even
more interestingly if you give it images
that don't look anything like imagenet
like sketches or it's more adversarial
image that data set it's able to get
performance that's much higher than
something that is trained in a
supervised Fashion on imagenet
yeah
it must be because they had massive
amounts of data
cost of learning or is it because of the
data set
um certainly the data set plays a huge
role here uh and the
um the diversity of the data that is
given will help it be able to do well on
these kinds of things
um that said there are a number of works
that have kind of tried to ablate the
role of self-supervised learning versus
the data set and have found that things
that are
um more self-supervised or more kind of
more similar to something like clip do
better than something that's trained in
a purely supervised fashion
cool um so to summarize contrastive
learning uh it's a very general and
effective framework uh and we've seen
how it can be used to con to compare and
contrast lots of different things
I one thing that's nice about it is that
you only need an encoder F Theta of X
you don't need a generative model of
your data and this means that you can
probably get away with a smaller model
than if you had used a generative model
um
the other thing that can be viewed as a
prose if you have some domain
information like augmentations that can
be incorporated into the algorithm to
generate other positives
the challenges is that negatives can be
hard to select uh
and as a result it often requires a
large batch size and so
this is a little bit kind of
the kind of other side of the coin with
respect to the generative modeling not
being required you can usually get away
with a smaller model but you need a
larger batch size oftentimes and so you
might still need a large amount of GPU
memory for example to train these kinds
of models
um and then the other challenge is that
it um it has been most successful with
augmentations uh like we talked about
and there might be domains where you
don't have augmentations available and
there are a couple solutions for that
but it's something that is still an open
area of research
the question is is contrastive learning
a good pre-training scheme for
generative modeling
um I guess I often view narrative
modeling as something that you do with
data that's unlabeled and so uh if
you're and one of the nice things about
unsupervised pre-training is you can get
a lot of juice out of unlabeled data and
so if your task is already something
that
um that can be done with unlabeled data
like generative modeling then it may be
that you don't need a good pre-training
method because maybe you already have a
lot of data that you can use
um
I guess more specifically I also I don't
know of any works that that pre-trained
with contrastive learning and then
fine-tuned on a narrative modeling task
but
um it's possible that there are some
works out there
yeah and this can this be combined with
like fine-tuning if for example you have
a multi-label problem so you know
different examples can either be in the
same classroom depending on the label
that you're in case of it can this be
combined with fine-tuning
so
um
so we talked about learning
representations and then you do often
fine-tune the representation you often
put it like some sort of classifier on
top of the representation then you can
fine-tune end to end are you thinking
about something other than that
uh I guess I'm thinking about the way
that you would generate the embedding
and whether you
you changed
you know yeah so you could also Imagine
fine-tuning with the contrast of loss uh
similar to how things like prototypical
networks are doing classification with
this kind of like this is looks very
similar to a classification loss and so
you could fine tune with something like
that
um
yeah so you could certainly do something
like that the definitely the default
that I've seen the vast majority of work
do is to free either freeze the
representation and put something on top
of that or additionally fine-tune end to
end but I could certainly imagine that
you could fine-tune with the contrast of
loss as well and if you can fit your
loss function in the form of something
like a contrastive loss you may actually
do better than that other approach
cool and then the last thing I like to
talk about in the last seven minutes is
how this relates to some of the learning
algorithms that we have talked about in
class
um and
as you might have guessed some of these
equations look a lot like the equations
that we saw in the non-parametric
keyshot learning lecture
uh and you can in many ways formulate an
algorithm
um a metal learning approach that looks
a lot like the contrastive approaches
we've talked about today
and so if you're given an unlabeled data
set say you're doing something like
simclear where you generate positives
and negatives by augmenting
then you can basically create a labeled
data set where you create an image class
by augmenting your example and you
create multiple examples from that class
by augmenting it multiple times
that will give you a data set for that
image class and then to create a task
what you'll do is you'll want to be able
to classify between different image
classes
now
um once you create can once you have
this labeled data set you can create
tasks that actually just run your
favorite meta learning algorithm
on this data
um and it turns out that there's
actually a very kind of
close mathematical relationship between
doing something like this with an
algorithm like prototypical networks and
the Sim clear algorithm that we talked
about in lecture
um there this this paper in the bottom
right goes in depth on that but there
are really two key differences
um and they're relatively small
differences in my mind the first is that
some clear samples only one
classification task per mini batch and
usually metal learning algorithms will
sample a mini batch of tasks
and the second difference is that
um some clear it's really going to look
at all pairs of negative examples or all
pairs of
yeah all pairs of of examples in your
batch whereas meta learning only
compares the query examples to the
support examples and never Compares and
contrast query examples with other query
examples
um so in this way you could perhaps view
the Sim clear classes being a little bit
this simply also be a little bit more
efficient with its batch because it's
going to compare and contrast everything
in the batch
um but otherwise these algorithms end up
being extremely similar
um and they also end up doing something
extremely similar in practice as well so
if you
um here's just one experiment in that
paper you
take it on label data set I think they
took the image.unlabeled data set they
augmented with the SIM clear
augmentations
and compared using simclear versus using
this approach with prototypical that
works in R2D2 where R2D2 is a it's an
optimization based metal learner that
has a number of kind of bells and
whistles to it
uh and you see that when you then kind
of pre-train these representations on
image that and then fine tune them on
these other image classification uh
problems you see extremely similar
performance between Sim clear and Proto
typical networks you also see very
similar performance between simclear and
R2D2
um and in some cases R2D2 is able to do
a little bit better as well
[Music]
mostly few shots but this problem this
is
yeah so actually this is actually not a
zero shot problem so
um it's pre-training on it's
pre-training representations with this
approach and then fine-tuning on the
entire data set from the entire training
data set from these data sets and so the
other difference that I sort of didn't
mention on this slide is on the previous
slide is that meta training and the
training time is very similar but what
happens at test time is actually a
little bit different so typically in few
shot learning we um
well like we'll give it a few examples
embed them and make a classification and
actually in this case at test time what
they're doing is they're they're
learning the representation With Better
Learning and then they're just
fine-tuning the whole network and that's
a little bit different from what we've
been doing in the previous lectures
uh
yeah so we're really just comparing the
representations that were learned rather
than the specific few shot learning
approach that happens at test time
could you imagine the bad sampling I
think with better anyone they would have
heard like more samples
but foreign
yeah so the question was
um like how do we like like
in metal learning like n and K you
choose n and K usually you choose an N
that's maybe smaller than 256
um at least that's certainly what a lot
of papers have done
um I can't remember exactly what they
did in this paper
um if you happy to follow up on it or
you could take a look at the paper and
I'm guessing that they probably use
something similar to 256 and so maybe
the values of those hyper parameters do
actually affect performance
yeah
so before it contrasts you uh video
augmentation right so if you assume that
each class has a view of when let's say
four or five examples for each Club it's
like a four a four or five short screen
for that plus in a way so I wanted to
ask does mixing this too so like when
you're a supervised view short model
can we include contrastive Rhythm into
training metal and approaches it doesn't
help
yeah so I guess first I do think that
it's very similar to one shot learning
because there's one positive one anchor
um and generally One-Shot learning is
harder than like five shot learning and
so I would suspect that you get better
representations from one shot learning
than five shot learning
um the other question is can you use
contrastive learning
[Music]
but we don't do anything intra support
like in in the support space or create
space just doing the an unsupervised
manner that's in in using introducing
contrastive learning there does it help
in the performance yeah so prototypical
that works it does this sort of like
aggregation in in the case where you
have more than one shot
um
and the question is if you do something
like that and additionally enter include
elements of of this which I think would
sort of be similar to training like both
one shot and five shot in a way because
one shot is very similar to this
um does that help and I I could see that
improving performance and I think that
the prototypical that works papers
showed that actually sometimes One-Shot
training can actually be better than
five shot trading when you test on five
shot because you're trading on something
harder
um so yeah
we never actually get the information
out of the support samples like we don't
train them in between like in our
surprise Manner and we also don't do
anything with the quiz
information
right right yeah so you could also use
these augmentations
um in addition to the labels that we
have in the meditation
um and that would be kind of like sort
of like a semi-supervised meta learning
thing as well and we'll probably talk
about that a little bit on Monday next
week
foreign
we talked about contrastive learning
on Wednesday this week we're going to be
talking about another form of
unsupervised pre-training which are
reconstruction based methods yeah so
that's the rest of contrastive learning
um as a couple reminders uh your project
proposal is due on Wednesday and the
homework is due next Monday